my instagrams coming back to life my
name's Kyle I'm new here at BuzzFeed and
I just moved to Manhattan before working
at BuzzFeed I'd spent a lot of time
outdoors taking photographs but now
since I live in New York City
I hardly photograph anything anymore so
for the next few days I'm going to
explore Manhattan and take the best
Instagram photo of New York City ever or
one that's just like good enough to post
so let's go so an important thing I
focus on with all my photos is location
so I'm gonna get downtown first and
check out the Manhattan and the Brooklyn
Bridge and hopefully get some good shots
there
[Music]
so I just got back to the office I am
scrolling through the photos now and
they did not come out so good I think I
need to take a new approach but I have
an idea
sorry for name Jason I've been falling
Instagram for counting a while he takes
pictures only of Manhattan and they are
freaking crazy-looking they are so so
cool it's gonna be mm and see if he
wants to meet up and take pictures so
it's the next day I just got off the
phone with Jason he said he can meet up
tomorrow in Brooklyn so that's the plan
what's up hey great time nice to meet ya
so I'm excited my rep retire grafite
tell yourself I'm Jason resort oh I'm a
Brooklyn based landscape and cityscape
photographer my images are known for
being bright sunrises and sunsets with
Manhattan as the backdrop and I also
like to really incorporate foreground
and big ground elements to make it more
of a landscape type of photo as opposed
to just a typical New York City thought
so let's go down to the waterfront we're
gonna take a few photos and I'm gonna
give you some tips and hopefully we'll
get something great
[Music]
so we spent all afternoon wandering
around Brooklyn and taking photos Jason
gave me lots of tips on how to improve
my photography and talked to me about
his approach to Instagram we finished
the day off taking a sunset photo of
downtown Manhattan before heading home
[Music]
before me and Jason split up the other
day he gave me three challenges to
complete one of them is to recreate
three famous Instagram photos so I'm
going to do one at the Brooklyn Bridge
one of the Manhattan Bridge and one of
the top of the rock number 2 pervert a
friend into one of my photos and finally
three wake up for sunrise so I get
anything like close to what Jason does I
would be so psyched today it's not
looking great it's really cloudy out but
I'm here so I'm gonna take the photos
anyways right nice to the Brooklyn
Bridge is another very popular Instagram
spot in Manhattan brews this blue one
right down here so Recreation number two
also kind of a failure unfortunately I
mean there's like a hundred people over
there taking Instagram engagement photos
pregnancy photos they're just like way
too busy getting shot right now for the
third recreation I'm gonna head back to
Manhattan and go to the top of
Rockefeller Center in Rockefeller Center
there's a lot of turns and not a lot of
signs
okay so updating at Rockefeller Center I
went there and it was a two-hour wait to
get in and it cost $35 I don't have $35
to take a picture yeah I didn't get any
good photos today day ones off - not a
great start on my own thing that
tomorrow
when I put some in my photo that'll be
good and then hopefully when I do my
early morning photo I'll get some like
really interesting light so we'll see
I'm prepared for the picture let's do it
I should get shirtless probably should
night so Eric decided to take it up a
notch take a shirt off of Instagram
we're going for the one-handed handstand
right now for Kyle
care about Kyle getting views I'll do
whatever for Kyle all right let's make
it happen
all right so I think we got the photo it
looks pretty cool Eric to the handstand
but he accidentally did it in class I'm
not flipping you guys off I am bleeding
I got glass in my finger so I'm gonna go
I have to go get it out
we got the picture though that's what
matters Wow okay good morning so I am up
and out of the house before 5:00 a.m.
and so far I'm not liking it it's dark
and it's kind of cold and there's no one
around
I'm gonna go take my picture now
all right so one hour later I made it
out here to Morris Canal State Park in
New Jersey I have an awesome view of the
city I'm just waiting for the Sun to
come up I'm excited it's freezing out
but I'm definitely awake now so that's
good
just waiting patiently so the Sun is
slowly starting to rise it is getting
way colder by the second right in the
water so the wind is whipping at my face
right now hands are free tonight for
today so update and the pictures looking
better by the second this is actually
this is really cool and it's actually
like really peaceful out here I don't I
never do this like just come out in the
morning no for like no music or anything
I'm just kind of hanging out by myself
and there's some geese over there I'm
still waiting for this guy to kind of
like light up the way I'm hoping it will
to make the photos more interesting for
now I'm gonna put myself in it coming
out rocks and those
the sky is starting to look really nice
so that's exciting it's getting more and
more red back there
alright literally keeps getting better
by the second look at that alright
that's pretty much it for sunrise you
know I was really hesitant about waking
up and coming out here but not a great
morning actually alright so is it the
best Instagram of New York City I mean
probably not but I think it's pretty
good and Jason even commented nice man
with with that among view so if you're
still watching I assume you like
photography so I will tell you a few
things that Jason told me one is really
plan your shot up he told me to get to
whatever destination I'm headed to 20 to
30 minutes before it's actually time to
shoot so number two is definitely check
the weather so to get those really
beautiful colors in the sky you actually
need to have some cloud coverage not a
whole lot you want to make sure there's
a gap in the horizon so the sunlight can
come through and bounce off those clouds
and number three is you don't need a
really crazy camera to get photos it's
all about timing light and Composition
and I think that's it hopefully the next
photo that I try to take I don't need to
wake up before him together
[Music]